monsieur le pen
je suis frappé dans cette campagne par
l'importance que l'opinion et la presse
accorde à la personnalité des candidats
à la présidence de la république dans
cette deuxième partie de l'entretien que
nous avons entamé voici 48 heures devant
les téléspectateurs français
je voudrais vous demander très
simplement de vous définir au fond à
travers votre vie politique que l'homme
est vous écoutez je crois que je suis un
homme d'action
un homme engagé dans la vie un homme
complet j'ose le dire qui a été forgé
par une période particulièrement
difficile puisque j'ai 45 ans j'ai donc
vécu tous les drames toutes les
aventures de notre pays toute sa vie
profondément est à peu près tout le
temps à l'endroit où les français
combattait ou souffraient le plus je
suis né en bretagne qui est déjà une
terre de contrastes une terre de combat
puisque c'est la lutte permanente de la
mer et du vent contre la terre et parce
que aussi c'était une période difficile
avant l'entre-deux-guerres je suis une
famille qui n'était pas riche et la vie
n'était pas très facile
j'ai donc été modelé assez rapidement
je crois à éprouver dans le bon sens
dans le sens du laboratoire du terme
éprouvé par la vie et je pense que
depuis j'ai contribué à renforcer ma
détermination mon jugement et je pense
que je suis un homme assez équilibré un
homme je pense explique la fois par son
milieu social c'est ses origines
terriennes sont sa vie son aventure
personnelle en quelque sorte
et justement je crois que il faut que
les gens sachent cela d'un homme qui
aspire à l'honneur exceptionnel
extraordinaire de les représenter ou de
les guider et bien
j'ai commencé ma vie je voulais dire en
bretagne dans cette terre à la fois
pauvre mais riche de spiritualité ou la
terre et la mer se mêlent comme on dit
d'ailleurs comme dit la devise de mon
pays natal la trinité-sur-mer à renoir à
ron moore sur terre et sur mer et j'ai
connu l'enfance de deux petits garçons
pauvres
j'ai suivi l'école de à la fois l'école
libre et l'école laïque dans une
ambiance je dois dire de patriotisme
d'admiration les écrans sommes des
hommes qui avaient fait la france plus
grande plus belle et plus libre et puis
est venue la guerre j'avais 11 ans au
moment de la guerre s'est déclenché une
guerre qui allait bien sûr modifier
l'avis d'énormément de français mais
bien sûr la mienne puisque mon père est
mort à la guerre avec eux c'est à la
suite de cela je suis devenu pupille de
la nation et mais j'ai connu avec tous
les français
les drames de la guerre les privations
de l'occupation elle-même le manque de
liberté et puis les bombardements la
peur et puis comme beaucoup de français
qui n'en parle pas et j'ai moi même pris
part à cette lutte en conservant chez
moi des armes de guerre alors que
j'étais presque encore un enfant ce qui
était considéré par les autorités
d'occupation comme un crime majeur et
qui en dans la zone interdite que je me
trouvais vallès sans discussion la peine
de mort je n'en ai jamais parlé parce
que je trouve que trop de gens depuis 30
ans ont bâti leur carrière personnelle
ou leur carrière politique sur des
actions dont ils n'ont pas toujours été
les responsables et sur la mort de
camarades qui n'ont pas fait cela pour
cela et si vous voulez je pense que la
guerre est un soleil qui mûrit les
hommes beaucoup plus vite j'ai donc été
un homme à 15 ans à 16 ans et quand la
libération est arrivé au moment où nous
avons reconquis la liberté j'ai été
profondément choqué de voir que certains
nombre de français considéraient cela
comme leur propriété personnelle et
essayer de régler des comptes ça a été
une de mes premières prises de
conscience politique
et puis je suis monté à paris faire mes
études
comme boursier ma bourse était très
insuffisante pour m'entretenir
malgré l'aide de ma mère qui était
couturière et j'ai dû travailler j'ai
été marin pêcheur pendant des temps
assez long
j'ai été mineur de fond j'ai été
ambulants des ptt enfin je connais les
problèmes des travailleurs autrement que
dans la littérature marxiste ou dans les
romans sociaux en tous les cas beaucoup
mieux que ceux qui en parlent si
fréquemment à la radio et la télévision
et puis un moment donné j'ai eu le
sentiment que mon pays l'europe la
france était en guerre en guerre avec le
communisme c'était la période de la
moment de la guerre froide
et puis on se battait on se battait date
des françaises battait très loin 18
mille kilomètres de chez nous dans des
conditions épouvantables
ils menaient une guerre qui est ignorée
du pays ignorés des français avec un
gouvernement qui les y avait engagé mais
qui ne les soutenait pas et poignardé
dans le dos par l'action du parti
communiste dont je rappelle qu'il allait
jusqu'à jeter les blessés qui revenait
l'anneau chine or des trains qui les
transportait et je me suis sentie l'a
appelée vers ce dont je pensais qu'il
portait avec l'honneur du pays et par
souci ils souffraient le plus je croyais
moi en la plus grande france
et bien j'ai mis mes attend en
conformité avec ma pensée j'ai quitté
doctorat de sciences économiques que je
faisais et je me suis engagé au premier
bataillon étranger de parachutistes où
j'ai servi comme sully et non je suis
allé en indochine et dois je rappeler
aux français qu'il y aura dans dix jours
vingt ans que dans la cuvette de dien
bien phu quelques milliers d'hommes qui
gardait l'honneur et le drapeau sont
morts ou ont été contraints à la
capitulation
je voudrais que cet avertissement qui
fut donné par notre histoire ne soit pas
complètement oublié car la suite des
événements allait prouver qu'il était au
combien nécessaire et puis j'ai vu là la
rentrée du corps expéditionnaire de 22
du tonkin en cochinchine avec ces
populations que nous abandonnions après
leur avoir juré fidélité et quand je
suis rentré en france en 1955
j'avais une grande colère politique
contre un régime
s'était couchée dans la boue et de la
défaite la quatrième république et je me
suis lancé dans la bataille j'ai été élu
député à 27 ans et je me suis trouvé
pratiquement leader d'un groupe
politique lancée dans la bataille
parlementaire à l'égal des leaders et
puis c'est le moment où monsieur guy
mollet monsieur mitrand le monsieur
mendès france autant briller le
contingent en algérie pour faire la
guerre et j'ai estimé qu'il était de mon
devoir de parlementaire capable de
porter les armes d'y aller avec le
contingent puisque dans le fond j'étais
d'accord pour préserver cette partie de
la france et l'indépendance énergétique
et et politique de ce grand ensemble du
sart alors je suis allé avec eux j'ai
servi aux côtés dé tous les camarades
français qui était je sais maintenant
comment faire proche et que les gens qui
m'en font reproche sont ceux qui portent
la responsabilité de cette guerre j'ai
cru aussi en 58 que un grand espoir
était né
j'ai été vite déçu car je me suis aperçu
une fois encore que l'on ne tenait pas
les promesses que l'on avait fait j'ai
été réélu député j'ai été rapporteur du
budget de la guerre j'ai eu des
responsabilités importantes et je me
suis battu dans la fidélité des
engagements de la france aux hommes
d'abord aux français qui étaient là bas
et ensuite à tous ces algériens à qui
nous avons juré à qui nous avions juré
par la voix des plus éminents de nos
chefs qu'il resterait français à tout
jamais j'avais d'ailleurs dans un autre
temps soutenu la candidature en 1957
d'un français d'algérie à paris comme un
breton ou abbas et je crois que c'est
tout à son honneur et au mien ce n'est
pas nous qui avons fauté dans cette
affaire et puis en 1962 et bien j'ai
payé le prix de mon engagement politique
j'ai été battu aux élections et je me
suis consacré à ma vie professionnelle
parce que je suis un professionnel de ma
profession et non un professionnel de la
politique et je dirige une maison de
disques et mon travail me permet de
nourrir une famille très unie est très
heureuse je dois le dire
dieu merci j'ai une femme qui est une
landaise et de trois enfants trois
filles et je ne suis revenu à la
politique que en 1972 que parce que j'ai
senti que le vraiment ça allait très mal
et qu'il fallait
les français comme moi reviennent à la
vie politique pour dire au pays la
vérité qu'on leur qu'on lui cache et
pour essayer de lui proposer des
solutions susceptibles de l'unifier et
de faire face à une crise que tout le
monde sent extrêmement proche et que
personne n'ose affronter en moi je dis
que le premier devoir d'un homme
politique d'un homme public c'est de
dire la vérité aux français ça n'est pas
d'essayer de capter sa confiance mais au
contraire de lui indiquer la voie même
si elle doit être dur même si elle doit
être difficile
la voie du salut et ça je crois que mon
programme de salut public et celui que
propose le front national et la droite
sociale populaire et nationale et bien
c'est cela l'avenir de la france et je
sais que vous le dirais dimanche quand
vous voudrez pour moi